[موسيقى]
اذا كانت هذه مقاطعه لكان تم تفتيش هذا
المبنى نحن تحت الثلج بلا منزل بدون اي
شيء دعونا نستعد للجنازات هل انتحر ماذا
علي ان افعل اين يمكنني ان اذهب
حاول الساعه الثانيه مساء امس انهار هذا
المبنى ربما هناك مئات المباني الاخرى مثل
هذا هناك الالاف تحت الالقاب حاليا
السلطات التركيه لن يسمح لنا بانقاذهم
بوسائلنا لكنهم لا يرسلون اي شخص للمساعده
هذا الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا
وشمال سوريا تسبب في فقدان ووفاه الكثير
من الاطفال بينما كتب عمر جديد لاخرين
بعدما نجح رجال الانقاذ في انتشالهم وحتى
الان لا توجد احصائيات دقيقه حول عدد
الوفيات في صفوف الاطفال لكن التوقعات
تشير الى انها ستكون مرتفعه
هم الحلقه الاضعف عند وقوع اي كارثه
انسانيه والزلزال المدمر الذي هز تركيا
وسوريا لم يتركهم في حالهم بل عبثت هزاته
بمسائر الكثير منهما انهم اطفال تركيا
وسوريا الذين ذاقوا مراره الزلزال حالات
انسانيه مؤلمه واخرى تبعث الامل كان
ابطالها اطفال وجدوا انفسهم بين ليله
وضحاها يعيشون وضعا لا تتحمله براءتهما
بلغه الارقام فان حصيله الوفيات من
الاطفال تبدو مرتفعه فنقلا عن صندوق الامم
المتحده للطفوله يونيسف فان حصيله الوفيات
من الاطفال تبدو مرتفعه ويصعب تحديدها
بدقه لحد الان
مقاس الاطفال في هذا الزلزال تلخصها صور
كثيره من هنا وهناك صور تتحدث عن نفسها
وتعكس هول الكارثه التي المت بالكثير منهم
واوجعت ذويهم
الطفله السوريه رغد كتب لها عمر جديد
ستعيشه يتيمه بعدما فقدت معظمه افراد
عائلتها بسبب الزلزال
حاله هذا الرضيع السوري لا يختلف عن حال
رغد فقد ولد وسط ركام متحديا هذه الكارثه
التي سرقت منه والدته اما هؤلاء الاطفال
فقد نفذوا بجلدهم من الموت بفضل هذا الثقب
الصغير الذي كان بالنسبه لهم بمثابه نافذه
حياه جديده وهذه الطفله بريئه ربما لم
تستوعب جيدا هول ما حدث واكتفت بالصمت
تعبيرا عن الصدمه
اما البعض فلم تسعه الدنيا من الفرحه
بعدما منحته فرصه ثانيه لمعانقه ابنه او
ابنته عكس اخرين الذين لم يجدوا سوى
الدموع لتوديع اطفالهم الذين رحلوا تحت
الانقاضى الذهبي العربيه
والى شبكه مراسل العربيه على الارض نتابع
التطورات لحظه بلحظه ينضم الينا زميل غسان
ابو لوزه موفد العربيه الى اسطنبول ومن
القميشلي عبر سكايب ايضا الزميل جمعه عكاش
مرحبا بكم ابدا بالقامشلي هناك مشكله
كبيره تواجه جهود الانقاذ في الشمال
السوري تتعلق بمشاكل تتعلق بالطرق بصعوبه
الوصول من قبل فرق الانقاذ التي تعلق
نشاطها بين الحين والاخر جمعه ضعنا في
الصوره في هذه النقطه
يعني الاشياء المنتظره الكبيره وهي
المساعدات الانسانيه القادمه من الدول
المانحه او المنظمات الامميه الكبيره
كالامم المتحده جامده خاصه في تركيا وهي
معناتها الامم المتحده قال ان لديها شحنات
كبيره من المواد الاغاثيه والطبيه عالقه
في تركيا يفهم بان الطرقات متقطعه ومتضرره
وبالتالي لا تستطيع الامم المتحده ادخال
هذه الشحنات عبر معبر باب الهوى الى مناطق
المعارضه اي الى شمال الغربي من سوريا وهي
المناطق الاكثر تضررا في سوريا من هذا
الزلزال والاقل من ناحيه الموارد سواء
الموارد الطبيه او البشريه او حتى يعني
الاليات الثقيله المطلوبه لرفع الانقراض
يعني جهود الاغاثيه جهود رفع الانقراض في
مستوياتها الدنيا وهو ما يعني
يفسر بارتفاع اعداد الضحايا نحن كنا نتحدث
قبل ساعتين عن 1612
اصبح العدد 1712 والان نحن نتحدث لربما عن
ارقام تقترب من الالفين شخص قتلوا جراء
هذا الزلزال في عمور المتزايده جمعه يتم
اخراجها من تحت الانقاض
نعم يعني يعني عدد كبير من الجرحى الذين
تم انشائها العمليات المعقده لهم داخل
المشافي فارقوا الحياه يعني في مشفى عفرين
العسكري لوحده شهد 83 حاله وفاه كانوا
هؤلاء قد وصلوا كجرحى يعني كمصابين من تحت
الارقام وصلوا الى هذا المستشفى يعني كان
هناك ثلاثه جثث فقط في مشفى واحد في مدينه
يعني جنديرس بسبب يعني عدم قدره طواقم
الدفاع وطواقم الانقاذ رفع الانقاض هناك
حديث عن وجود حوالي 150 شخص فارقوا الحياه
في هذه البلده الصغيره 84 مبنى مدمر يعني
هل
تتحدثك هل هي خيم هل هي مخيمات يتم
اقامتها اشعر ايضا ان هناك برد شديد يبدو
الطقس سيئا للغايه ايضا
يعني ميسون مع حلول الليل وساعات الليل
يعني تصبح درجه الحراره ادنى من الصفر
مئويه اما بالنسبه لهذه الخيم خلفي فهي
مجموعه من القيم ومن يغادر منازلهم
يعني خوفا من حدوث اي اهزات ارتداديه اخرى
هذه الخيام
[موسيقى]
الاجراءات الحكوميه التركيه في خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه
رشا بدايه اود الاشاره الى ما او ردته
وسائل الاعلام تركيه محليه قبل قليل عن
وزير الداخليه التركي
قال فيها ان 48 ساعه المقبله ستكون هامه
وحاسمه في عمليه انقاذ العالقين تحت
الارقام كما ايضا نقلت وسائل الاعلام
المحليه عن وزير الداخليه ان هناك 10,000
من قوات الدرك تم توجيههم الى المناطق
المنكوبه وايضا قال بان هناك 600 جثمان في
كهرمان مرش تم التعرف عليهم
ودفنهم هذه اخر يعني الانباء التي ترد
بحسب وسائل الاعلام المحليه التركيه هنا
وعمليا ما زالت عمليات
انقاذ والاغاثه والمساعده مستمره مدار
الساعه كما قال الوزير بان 48 ساعه
المقبله عامه وحاسمه
ان كان من ناحيه سرعه عمليات الانقاذ
والتجاوب معها وهو ما تبدله السلطات
التركيه ضد الاقصى جودها
لانقاذ
العالقين تحت الانقاض وايضا المنكوبين
الذين باتوا بلا ماوى الان نتحدث عن اكثر
من 52 الف تم ايوائهم في مراكز سواء
بمدارس او صلاه رياضيه او خيام او حتى
فنادق رشا ايضا هناك لا تنسي رشا بان هناك
عاصفه ثلجيه تضرب البلاد وبالتالي هي تعقد
من امور الاغاثه والمساعده ايضا تلقي
بظلالها ثقيله والقاسيه جدا والبرد القارس
على هؤلاء المنكوبين الذين باتوا الان بلا
ماوى او بلا منازل تحديدا هم الان في خيام
وفي مدارس وبالتالي هم بحاجه الى مساعدات
عاجله سواء كانت
للتدفئه او اغذيه وما الى ذلك اذا كان
لديك غسان بعض المعلومات التفصيليه
اردوغان يقول انه تلقى اتصالات من سبعين
دوله واربعه عشره منظمه على استعداد
لتقديم الدعم لتركيا هل ثمه وصول لهذه
المساعدات تنسيق جدول زمني يشرح التفاصيل
عمليه رشا وصل حتى الان يعني حسب ما اعلنت
السلطات
فرق مساعدات فرق اغاثيه من اربعه عشره
دوله وصلت الى تركيا وتوجهت الى المناطق
الجنوبيه الاكثر تضررا والمنكوبه هناك
للعمل على المساعده والاغاثه والانقاذ
هناك وهو ايضا ما اشارت اليه الحكومه
التركيه بان عمليات الانقاذ
يتم تكثيفها في تلك المناطق وهي المناطق
الاكثر تضررا ايضا هناك عشرات الدول كما
قالت قال الرئيس اردوغان بانها قدمت
مبادرات للمساعده وتقديم المساعده الى
تركيا ايضا اعلن الرئيس بانه هناك اكثر من
خمس مليارات دولار تخصيصه لتقديم
المساعدات والمعاونات الى تلك المناطق
المنكوبه لكن على ما يبدو ان هذا الرقم
ربما يعني
يكون بحاجه الى مزيد من الاموال لمواجهه
الكارثه غير المطبوخه كما وصفها الرئيس
اردوغان اليوم خلال كلمه له وقال بان هذا
الزلز
ال ما ابلغوه خبراء وعلماء في الزلازل هنا
وبالتالي
كان هناك ايضا تصريح واضح للرئيس بان
الاعداد اعداد القتلى مرشحه للازدياد بشكل
كبير
وربما الاعداد تشهد قفزات كبيره في اعداد
رقم المصابين نعم هناك يمكن التوقف امامه
ايضا وهو المتعلق بالناجين اردوغان كان قد
اعلن انه تم نجاه
800 الف
حتى اللحظه هل هذا الرقم
تزايد قل يعني الارقام ايضا فيما يتعلق
بالناجين هي نقطه مهمه
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي هناك مخاوف من هذه الهزات ربما
تضرب بعض يعني تتاثر فيها المباني خصوصا
تلك المتصدعه او اللي
تعرضت
لتاثرت بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد يوم
امس
الى قوه ضربات الارتداديه او الهزات
الارتناديه اضافه الى الطقس السيء للغايه
جعلت وزير الداخليه التركيه يصف هذه
الكارثه بانها الاخطر في تاريخ تركيا اعود
مره اخرى الى زميلي جمعه عكاشه من
القميصلي جمعه كنا نتحدث في نقطه مهمه وهي
المتعلقه باعاقه وصول المساعدات نتيجه
الصعوبه الكبيره في مرور هذه المساعدات
على الطرق كان هناك حديث عن معبر باب
الهوى ولكن هل من منفذ اخر يمكن اللجوء
اليه لعبور هذه المساعدات
رشا نعم هذا هو الجانب الاكثر اهميه هناك
منافذ اخرى لكن هذه المنافذ تقع تحت سيطره
يعني النظام السوري نتحدث عن مطار دمشق
الدولي مطار حلب الدولي ايضا الموانئ في
مدينه اللاذقيه الساحليه حتى الان لا يوجد
اي تفاهم بين المعارضه والنظام لايجاد
طريقه او اهليه لادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه التي وعدت فيها اكثر من سته
واربعين دوله وحتى ايضا منظمات يعني الامم
الامم المتحده
هناك تحدي من نوع اخر وهو علاقه الدول
المانحه مع النظام السوري كما تعرفين
الدول العربيه معظم الدول العربيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي امريكا هذه الدول ترفض
التطبيع مع النظام السوري وبالتالي لا
تقيم اي علاقات معها اليه ادخال او سبل
ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه يجب ان تمر اما
من مطار دمشق او مطار حلب او من الموارد
في اللاذ كل هذه المنافذ البحريه والجويه
يسيطر عليها النظام لا يوجد حتى يعني
تنسيق في المجال الانساني نحن نتحدث عن
كارثه انسانيه الا ربما يعني تستطيع بعض
الدول الهيئات يعني يعني وضع الخلافات مع
النظام جانبا بهدف مساعده السريه سواء
كانوا او معارضه او حتى يعني رماديين كما
يسمون هنا وهو المطلوب وهما يطالب بمعظم
المنظمات المدنيه والمنظمات المعنيه
بالامور الاغاثيه في العموم سوريا في جميع
المناطق هذه نقطه مهمه للغايه التي اشار
اليها زميل جمعه عكاش شكرا لك جمعه من
القميص لي وايضا زميلي غسان ابو لوز موفد
العربيه من اسطنبول شكرا لكما وتغطيه
مستمره سنتابع مع شبكه مراسل العربيه على
الارض التطورات صندوق الامم المتحده
للطوارئ يقول انه خصص 25 مليون دولار
للمساعده الانسانيه للزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واقف
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
ونبقى معكم مشاهدينا في تحديث اخير
للارقام اداره الكوارث التركيه تقول
ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى
3703 حالات والجرحى الى
22,286 ينضم اليها من باريس وكورتي عضو
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود مرحبا بك سيد جون
هناك تساؤلات عديده في هذه اللحظات حول
كيفيه وصول المساعدات الى المناطق
المتضرره هناك دوله ذات سياده وهي تركيا
يمكن الوصول اليها بالتعامل مع الحكومه
التركيه ولكن ماذا عن سوريا هي منقسمه ما
بين مناطق قادعه للنظام ومناطق اخرى خاضعه
للمعارضه
هذه مشكله ملحمه
من حيث ارسال المواد ومواد الدعم الطبيه
الاخرى الى الشعب السوري
لابد لنا ان نجد بعض الطرق التي يمكن من
خلالها دعم شركائنا المحليين
في سوريا
والعمل على تزويد المواد
والمستلزمات الطبيه في الميدان
اننا نشره ببالغ القلق بزب بسبب
الطبيعه
الاوضاع السياسيه في سوريا بحيث لا يمكن
ايصال المساعدات الى بعض المناطق وكما
تعلمون في مناطق الشمال في سوريا
هناك ايضا اماكن يصعب فيها ايصال المواد
فضلا عن مشكلتي وجود المياه النظيفه
لذا فهناك اكثر من مشكله فضلا عن مشكله
الكوارث الكارثه الكارثه التي ضربت البلاد
فهناك الاوضاع السياسيه
ومن خلال
احاديثنا من مع مسؤولي
منظمتنا كنا قد طلبنا بتطوير نوع من
الاتصالات مع السلطات السوريه
وماذا كانت نتيجه هذه مع الاتصالات هل
اعربت الحكومه السوريه عن السداديها
للتعاون معكم لايصال
تخضع للمعارضه ستسمح بعبور لهذه المساعدات
عبر منافذها
في المرحله الحاليه من الصعب ان نعلم
ما هي الاجابات من قبل السلطات الموجوده
في في دمشق وهناك مناشدات من تركيا ومن
دول اخرى كانت قد وجهت الى السلطات في
سوريا من اجل السماح بادخال المواد
وهناك فريق موجود في المنطقه الجنوبيه وقد
تدرب على العمل في سوريا وعلى المناطق
الحدوديه
التركيه السوريه هو اننا
متاكدون انهم سوف يستطيعون على ايصال
المواد اذا ما سمح لهم
وسوف يحاولون ايضا ان يقدموا الدعم الى
المستشفيات بالمواد الضروريه والمواد
الطبيه والعمل على الدعم النفسي كما
اخبرتكم
لا بد من وجود اتصالات
بحيث يتم ابعاد مشاكل الخلافات السياسيه
والامنيه
والتركيز
على سماح لجزء من فريقنا للتوجه الى
المناطق المنكوبه وخاصه ان فريقنا مستعد
للقيام بهذه المهمه لكن في ظل هذه الظروف
الصعبه لا استطيع ان اؤكد بان الامر سوف
تكون سوف يكون بتلك سهوله وكيف يمكن
السلطات في سوريا ان تسمح بايصال هذه
المساعدات لكننا سوف نبقي على طريق نفس
طريقه العمل التي اعتمدناها ابان الحرب
بابقاء المواد وكافه
اللوجيسيات جاهزه
لاستخدامها عند الحاجه اليها
لديك خبره كبيره في التعامل مع هذه
الكوارث في هذه المنظمه العريقه منظمه
اطباء بلا حدود في ظروفك هكذا مع طقس سيء
مع صعوبه في المرور على الطرق كيف كان
يمكن توصيل المساعدات في اصعب المحن الى
المحتاجين لديكم خبره في هذا المجال
نعم ان الاوضاع صعبه للغايه فالاجواء
الاحوال الجويه السيئه فهي التسديد من
مخاطر ايصال
المواد والمساعدات التركيه لديها فرق
متدربه
مع الهلال الاحمر التركي وعلى ايصال
المساعدات وخاصه في مناطق الجنوب التي
بدات تعجب باعداد الجرحى وكانت تركيا قد
طالبت دعما دوليا
وتم توجيهها من قبيل كافه المواد
والمعدات الطبيه لمساعده
المستشفيات والمنشاه الطبيه لكن الامر قد
يستغرق وقتا وسوف يكون محفوفا بالصعوبات
والسلطات التركيه سوف يكون لديها ردود
افعال سريعه على عكس نظيرتها الموجوده في
سوريا فيما يتعلق في تقديم المساعدات في
ومما يزيد الامور صعوبه هي الاحوال الجويه
السيئه بحيث النظام الطبي قد يكونوا في
حاله شلل بسبب سنوات طويله من الحرب
وهناك مشكله نازحين الذين كانوا قد عانوا
معانوه لسنوات طويله من الحرب كما قلنا
سابقا واننا نشعر بالقلق ازاء طريقه كيفيه
تفعيل الانشطه المطلوبه في سوريا لدينا
شركات مع بعض الجهات المحليه في سوريا
ونسع من خلالها الوفاء بكافه الاحتياجات
الطبيه
والانسانيه لكن الامر الاكثر صعوبه ايضا
بالنسبه للسلطات التركيه هو تنظيم
المساعدات الدوليه لان
عندما تكون يكون اعداد الاشخاص الذين هم
بحاجه لمساعده كثر فقد تبدا الامور لتدخل
بحاله من الفوضى وتظهر حاله من التوتر لان
اناسا كثر لهم بحاجه لتنقل هذه المساعدات
لذا فان الحكومه التركيه مطالبه بتنسيق
بتنسيق هذه المساعدات بالتعاوني مع
المنظمات المجتمع المدني
لكافه هذه المساعدات ومواد العون التي
تاتي من الخارج والعمل على تنظيمها بشكل
جيد طيب في اجابه مختصره هناك رقم صادم
عرضات الامم المتحده اليوم منظمه الصحه
العالميه انه ربما تصل نتيجه هذه الكارثه
اعداد المتضررين قد تصل الى 20 مليون شخص
وهذا رقم كبير للغايه
نعم
الناس الذين يعانون سلفا من فقر مدفع
ويعانون من القيود المفروض الى درجه كبيره
في الشمال السوري
يعجز الوصف عنها فهم قد تاثروا بالصوره
مباشره
وخاصه اولئك الناس الناس الذين فقدوا
منازلهم
فحجم المساعده والعون
الذي ياتي
اليهم من الخارج يجب ان ينصب الان
لانه قد يستغرق فتره طويله فنحن لا نتحدث
عن ايام او اسابيع بل اطول بكثير لدى الاب
قد تكونوا ثلاثه اشهر او اكثر لذا فان
المساعده يجب ان تبدا بحيث يتم تتم
الاستجابه لهذه الاوضاع الانسانيه
لانه للاسف قد يستغرق الامر عده اشهر لتصل
الى بعض المناطق التي يصعب الوصول اليها
من اجل عودتها الى حالها الطبيعي وايصال
المواد الغذائيه وغيرها ولهذا السبب فان
المساعدات التي تاتي من منظمات مثل اطباء
العالم التي يجب ان تبدا الان من خلال
برنامج اغاثي الذي لن يحل لن يدخل الى حيز
التنفيذ خلال بضعه ايام بل سوف يستغرق
اشهر والا
وان لم نسعى لتسريع فان اناسا كثر سوف
يفقدون
كثر من اقاربهم او احبائهم فهناك تحديات
كثيره
ولابد من العمل على تسريع الاستجابه
لهؤلاء المتضررين
وخاصه في خلال الاسابيع والاشهر القادمه
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو نشرته جماعه الخوذ
البيضاء للدفاع المدني عمليات انقاذ لعدد
من المدنيين من تحت ركام المباني جراء
زلزال العنيف الذي طال بلده الدانه في
شمال غرب سوريا وسط هطول غزير للامطار
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
الحركه عمو
نور نور
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
على شاشه العربيه الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي يجري اتصالا هاتفيا برجب
طيب اردوغان ويعلن مصر لتقديم المساعده
كان رئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي ايضا
قد اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا مع بشار الاسد بعد
قطيعه سياسيه دامت لسنوات ايضا في هذا
الصدد هناك انباء تشير وفقا لوكاله
الانباء السوريه عن حدوث هزه ارضيه شعر
بها بعض السكان في حلب واللاذقيه وحمص
سنتابع هذه التطورات ايضا مشاهد الدمار
التي خلفها الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا اعادت
صور اطفال سوريين غطى ثيابهم غبار حطام
المنازل المدمره والحيطان المتهاويه على
اجسامهم الصغيره بين هؤلاء طفله حديثه
الولاده تم انقاذها من تحت الركام لتبدو
على جسمها جروحها كبيره
ببطانيه مغبره رميه لتغطيتها انتشل عدد من
الرجال مولوده جديده من تحت الركامه
وحملوها بعيدا عن حطام ابقى تحته والدتها
واخفت انفاسها الاخيره فمن رحم المعاناه
يولد الامل والده الطفله وفق مواقع
التواصل لقيت حتفها بعد ولادتها مباشره
ولاقت عائلتها المكونه من سبعه اشخاص
مصيرا مشابها
ناشطون اكدوا ان مقطع الفيديو يعود للسيده
سوريه مهجره من منطقه دير الزور اسمها
عفراء هذه الام هربت باطفالها من القصف
والمعارك والتمست رحمه جدران منزل واقع في
ناحيه جنديرس التابعه لمنطقه عفرين في حلب
غير ان هذه الجدران المتهالكه اصلا عجزت
عن الصمود في مواجهه الزلزال بقوه سبع
درجات فاصله سبعه على مقياس ريختر زلزال
اسفر عن مئات القتلى والاف الجرحى وسط نقص
كبير في المشافي والمعدات الطبيه ففي
سوريا كل مصاب او ناجا من تحت الحطامى
مشروع ضحيه جديده
الاعداد تتزايد ايضا من الضحايا والمصابين
زلزال تركيا حل دقيقه واحده على الاطراق
والسوريين فانهى حياه الالاف هو مسح معالم
وفرق وفرق عائلات دقيقه الموت كما وصفت
غيرت حياه الملايين عددها الصغار نسبيا
كان كفيلا بمقتل اكثر من 4000 شخص وترك ما
يفوق عددا اكبر منهم مرميين اما في
الشوارع او في ممرات المشافي ان توفرت
اصلا
تونه ثانيه ليس اكثر وقعها مدمر
وارتداداتها اكثر تدميرا ولا تزال متواصله
تلك هي مده زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وغير حياه اكثر من ثلاثه وعشرين مليون شخص
زلزال بقوه 7.9 درجه ضرب في السادس من
فبراير على عمق نحو 17 كيلو مترا قرب
مدينه غازي عنتاب جنوبي تركيا اي على عمق
عشره كيلومترات فقط قرب مدينه كهرمان مرعش
وكانت الساعه حينها الواحده وسبعه عشره
دقيقه بتوقيت جرينتش ووفق شهود الزلزال
استمر دقيقه واحده وصفت بدقيقه الموت
مدمرا المباني في المناطق المذكوره ونوافذ
منازل في مدن تبعد نحو 300 وخمسين كيلو
مترا شرقا مثل ديار بكر
الزلزال في سوريا لم يكن اخف بل اركع
مباني متهالكه تحاول جاهده التماسك بعد
حرب استمرت 12 عاما لتتجدد صور الحطام
وانتشال الجثث والمصابين والذين قدروا
بالالاف
بعد 11 دقيقه من الزلزال الاول تعرضت
المنطقه لهزه ارتداديه بلغت قوتها 6.7
درجه لتبدا الكارثه حيث لم تنتهي سابقتها
زلزال اخر اعقبها بقوه 7.5 درجه تالته هزه
اخرى بقوه 6 درجات في فتره ما بعد الظهر
مع توقعات بامتداد النشاط الزلزلي الى
فجوه مجاوره
متى ما تيسر والانصات لهمهمه عالقين تحت
الانقاض تغص المشافي بالمصابين الذين
ملئوا الممرات دون قدره على علاجهم فيما
اخرون نفذوا من براثن الزلزال لتتكسر على
اجسادهم عاصفه ليست اقل رحمه
ونبقى في المتابعه الميدانيه لتاثيراتي
وتداعيات هذا الزلزال وجهود الانقاذ ينضم
الينا الصحفي احمد ابو لؤي من حلب من ريف
حلب مرحبا بك احمد حلب من اكثر المدن التي
تضررت بشكل كبير مما حدث نتيجه هذا
الزلزال كانت بها مخيمات للنازحين
واللاجئين منذ سنوات الحرب كيف تبدو
الصوره لديك الان
نعم تحياتي
هلا عن وقلق وخوف يؤرق السوريين وتخوفات
من عوده الجلاجل بقوتها الاولى كزلال الذي
حصل من قرابه الاربعون ساعه ففي صباح
اليوم وفي تمام الساعه السادسه والربع
صباحا حصلت هزه ارتداديه
تسالت بعدها
باربعه ساعات هزه اخرى في تمام الساعه
12:30 طبعا منذ قليل من قرابه الساعه في
تمام الساعه السادسه مساء ايضا كان هنالك
هز ارتداديه
او ضع مساويه يمر فيها السوريون بعموم
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا سواء في مناطق ادلب
او في ريف حلب عائلات باكملها شردت ما
زالت في العراق
الاشجار تحت اغصان الزيتون
ومنهن من
ذهب
لاقربائه في الذين يعيشون في العربيه
لربما هي
مكان امن بشكل اكثر طبعا ما زال له هنالك
المئات من العائلات تحت النقاد
هذا ما كنت ساسال عن وجود الانقاذ هل هي
متواصله هل تعوق طبيعه الطقس الطرق جهود
الانقاذ
نعم عزيزتي يعني بالنسبه
الانقاذ اليوم يكون
فرق الدفاع المدني اضافه بشبان متعاونين
من ابناء المناطق معهم ما زالت
ما زالت فرق الدفاع المدني جاهدين بالبحث
تحت
الركام على العالقين منهم من
مازال على قيد الحياه ومنهم ان وافتهم
المنيه طبعا
فرقه دفاعهم مناشدين وهم بحاجه ماسه
لادخال الاليات الادوات الكافيه
لاخراج العالقين تحت الركام تعهدت العديد
من الدول العربيه وغيرها
بادخال
المساعدات لكن حتى الان لم يستجيب لم يكون
هنالك استجابه وطبعا مع العلم ان مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا هي مناطق معارضه
والشريان الوحيد
هو معبر باب الهواء وحتى الان لم يتم اي
استجابات واحصائيات القتلى ما زال
بالارتفاع حيث
الاحصائيا النهائيه
لما بالنسبه لاعداب الجرح تجاوزت 2200
مصاب اما بالنسبه
للابنيه التي دمرت بشكل كلي وصل عددها
للانسان وعشر اغنياء ام والمباني التي
تعرضت للتصدعات او دمرت بشكل جزئي وصل
عددها الى 520 مبنى طبعا هذه المعلومات
حسب الدفاع المدني اما بالنسبه للوضع
الصحي اليوم استمرار كلي في المشافي في
المراكز الصحيه في المستوصفات ايضا هم
بحاجه لتوادر طرق طبيه ليس هناك كوادر
طبيه
بحاجه الى ادويه من اجل المصابين الخارجين
من تحت الان منهم ممن تعرض على الردود
للجروح الطفيفه ومنهم من تازم وضعه النفسي
بسبب
بقاء تحت الانقاذ الاشاعات طويله يعني
الوضع
بالعموم هو وضع ماساوي بكل ما تعنيه
الكلمه طيب اليوم هل اختلف المشهد عن
الامس هل مجرد جهود افضل للانقاذ نعلم ان
الامر يحتاج الى تنسيق ما بين النظام وقوى
المعارضه لان هذه المنطقه تشهد او يعني هي
تحت سيطرت قوى المعارضه بشكل كبير هل هناك
تحسن ام ان الامور تزداد سوءا احمد
اليوم الحصار على من قبل النظام السوري هو
ليس فقط سياسي مع الاسف اليوم اصبح حصار
انسان فلا يوجد جهود لا يوجد تعاون ابدا
لم يدخل اي شيء من مناطق النظام السوري
لهذه المناطق بل كما ذكرت منذ قليل هنالك
شبان متطوعون مع يتعاونون مع الفرق
الفرق الانقاذ
الدفاع المدني من اجل اخراج العالقين
بادوات بسيطه
كلها جهود ذاتيه داخليه لم تنجح المساعدات
الخارجيه في الوصول اليهم بعد
نعم لم تنجح ابدا اي نوع من
انواع اداب بالدخول الى هذه المناطق نعم
احمد ابو لؤي الصحفي من ريف حلب شكرا لك
احمد
هذا وقالت كبيره مسؤولي مكتب الطوارئ
بمنظمه الصحه العالميه ان عدد المتضررين
بزلزال المدمر الذي اودى بحياه الالاف في
تركيا وسوريا قد يصل الى 23 مليونا مضيفه
امام اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه الصحه
التابعه للامم المتحده ان من بين
المتضررين نحو خمسه ملايين في حاله ضعف
من المحتمل ان يتعرض 23 مليون شخص بينهم
نحو مليونين من الفئات السكانيه الضعيفه
الى جانب اكثر من 300 وخمسين الفا من كبار
السن ونحو مليون و400 الف طفل لقد تضررت
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه والبنيه التحتيه
الصحيه في جميع انحاء المناطق المتضرره
ولا سيما في تركيا وشمال غربي سوريا الى
جانب الدمار الهائل تعطلت الطرق في العديد
من المناطق وعبر الحدود داخل شمال غرب
سوريا تدرك منظمه الصحه العالميه قدره
تركيا القويه على الاستجابه وتعتبر ان
الاحتياجات الرئيسيه التي لم تتم تلبيتها
قد تكون في سوريا على المدى القريب
والمتوسط
وينضم الينا دكتور نجيب ابو كراكي استاذ
علم الزلازل في جامعه الاردنيه مرحبا بك
دكتور معنا حول هذه التداعيات الخاصه بهذا
الزلزال ربما العنوان ما زال مستمر دكتور
وهو زياده عدد الهزات الارتداديه
المصاحبه لهذا الزلزال العنيف الذي وقع
كيف يمكن توقع القادم لان البعض يرى ان
هذه الهزات الارتداديه هي عامل صعب ايضا
في جهود الانقاذ
طبعا في الواقع
توقع المنطقي وان تستمر هذه الاساتذه
الارتداديه بتناقص من حيث العدد ومن حيث
القوه ولكن ربما قد تستمر يعني حاله
الاضطراب هذه باسابيع او لا ربما ايضا
اكثر من ذلك طيب دكتور
قوى زلازل في منا
طق ولكن
هذه الزلازل وان هناك ظاهره اخرى اصبحت
ترتبط بها او تؤدي الى تاثير عنيف لها وهي
التغير المناخي ام ان ليس هناك صله ما بين
الموضوعين
الابحاث في هذا الموضوع يعني ما زالت غير
ناضجه وتحتاج الى جهود اكبر لاثباتها من
حيث المبدا يعني كعلم الزلازل لو قد الراي
يعني هذا العلم قليل ما يمكن ان يؤثر على
الزلازل من الظواهر التي تحصل على سطح
الارض هذا طبعا في الوضع الاني لكن
الدراسه على مدى بعيد على مدى يعني عشرات
السنين القادمه ما هو تاثير برضو او ربما
مئات السنين من التغيرات المناخيه هل
سيكون لها تاثير من ناحيه اذابه على سبيل
المثال الجليد اللي موجود في الاقطاب
والتغيير اماكن بعض الكتل من مناطق اخرى
الى الارض هل ستؤثر هذا في الواقع حتى
الان ما زال يعني في طور
في طور بدائي جدا كابحاث لكنه نسج جدا
كاشاعات كتخمينات دكتور فيما يتعلق
بالجغرافيا هل هي تلعب دورا حقيقيا في
مساله قوه الزلز عنفه بمعنى انه قد يقع
زلزال في منطقه ما من الكره الارضيه تكون
تداعيته اعنف واشد من منطقه اخرى
العوامل التي تجعل ابتداعيات اعنف
والخسائر اكبر يعني اول شيء هو نوع حدود
الصفائح المعنيه في عنا ثلاث انواع من
الحدود الصفائح وتركيب ايضا من الاحيان
المركبه من بعضهم مع بعض اختارهم هو
الحدود التصادميه كما هو الحال في منطقه
شمال الصفيحه العربيه المنطقه التي حصل
بها يعني هذا الزلزال هذه واحده
تداعيات ايضا يمكن ان تكون تتعمق اذا كان
البناء سيئا اذا كان هنالك فقر اذا كان في
هنالك يعني عدم اهتمام ببناء او عدم
الاهتمام بالتوعيه السكانيه في هذا المجال
اذا جاء الناس هذا على حين غير وايضا عامل
مفاقم جدا وهو عامل طبيعي عندما يحصل
الزلزال في ساعه متاخره من الليل مثل هذه
الساعه وكل الناس مجتمعين يعني في بيوتهم
وغرف نومهم هذا في الواقع يفاقم
الخسائر لانه قليلين بيكونوا من الذين
يعني لو حصلت النهار بيكونوا في اعمالهم
او في الشوارع شبه ذلك يكونوا بشكل طبيعي
كثيرا العوامل التي تؤدي الى مفاقمه وايضا
الطقس في هذه المنطقه يعني نفكر بظروف هذه
الكارثه في الواقع كثير جدا من الظروف
المضاده الظروف السلبيه اثرت فيها منها
الطقس ومنها برضو التشرد ومنها
التهجير ومنها الاوضاع الغير
المستقع فيه فجرا طبعا بالتاكيد التوقيت
هذا له يعني بالتاكيد زياده الخسائر بمعدل
30 40% اللي هم كانوا من الممكن ان يكونوا
خارج المناطق
التي تتاثر بهذا الزلزال لو كان الوضع
نهارا
نعمارات او البنايات وهي تسقط كهكذا في
لحظه واحده هل هذا هو طبيعي في حاله زلزال
من هذا النوع وبهذه الدرجه
زلزال اولا به طاقه هائله وهو كبير جدا
والابنيه تقاوم الى حد معين لكن اذا جاء
الزلزال يعني اقوى بكثير من مقاومه هذه
الابنيه لا نستغرب يعني ما الذي يمكن ان
يحصل هذا في الواقع هو التشبيه يعني
الحقيقي لهذا الموضوع اذا جاء الانسان
ضربه قويه على حين غره على سبيل المثال
بالتاكيد انه سيفقد وعيه لكن اذا جاءت هذه
الضربه بشكل اخف ممكن انه يقاوم هذا نمثل
الانسان بهذه العماره وما يمكن ان يكون قد
حصل لهذه الابنيه من
طاقه اكبر بكثير من ما صممت كي تقاومه هذه
يعني ان هناك درس مستفاد من هذه التجربه
ان طبيعه المبانه التي سيتم اقامتها في
مرحله الاعمار يجب ان تقوم على اساس معين
لمقاومه هذه الزلازل ام ان هذا الامر هو
امر غير ممكن في الحقيقه يعني
حقيقه كل زلزال يضيف معلومات اضافيه ويمكن
ان يحسن من الاستراتيجيات المستقبليه
للتخفيف من الخسائر للتخفيف لا يمكن
الغائها في الواقع هذا شيء متفق عليه يعني
حتى في اليابان عندما يحصل زلزال في مناطق
من حيث المبدا مبنيه كي تقاوم الزلازل
ويتفاجا بانها لم تقاوم يكون السبب ان
الزلزال جاء يعني باقوى من ما كان مصممه
له هذه الابنيه اتحدث عن زلزال كوبي في
اليابان 1995 والذي سبب ما لا يلعن 5000
قتيل ومناظر للجسور المهدمه بشكل بشع جدا
طبعا هذا كان ناتج عن انه يعني تصميم كان
شيء وما جاء به الزلزال شيء اخر التصميم
كان ان تقاوم هذه الابنيه ما يسمى بتسارع
ارضي يساوي ثلاثه من الجاذبيه الارضيه لكن
في الواقع جاءت التسارعات بانها ثمانيه
بالعشره يعني
دكتور ما بين ارتفاع المبنى وعدد الطوابق
التي به وما بين قوه الزلزال البعض يعتقد
انه اذا كانت المباني منخفضه او ليست
شاهقه الارتفاع يمكن ان يقلل هذا من عدد
الضحايا او الخسائر
من ناحيه ممكن هذا ان يقبل لكن في بعض
الاحيان يعني بتكون مواصفات الزلزال
ومواصفات وموجات الزلزاليه التي تاتي لهذه
الابنيه تكون يعني مناسبه كي تدمر الطابق
الرابع مثلا وبعضها قد تكون يعني
مواصفاتها ترددها الى اخره بعض المواصفات
الفيزيائيه لها تكون مثلا تدمر الطابق
الثامن وهكذا يعني في الواقع هذه ليست
قاعده عامه الا انه يعني اذا كان الانسان
تحت ردم على سبيل المثال اربعه طوابق هذا
اسهل من ان يكون تحت رد من 20 طالب طيب
هناك دراسات بدات تظهر خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه تشير الى انه يمكن
استشعار الزلزال وان بعض الاشخاص قالوا في
تصريحتهم التي سبقت التي اعاقبت ما حدث
بانهم بالفعل كانوا قد شعروا ببعض الدوار
ببعض الصداع هل هذا صحيح دكتور
اثناء الزلزال ولا قبل وقوعي بدقائق
يعني قبله بدقائق هذا مشكوك به قد يعني
الانسان اذا حصل هزه ارضيه خفيفه
وحركته في الواقع فهي ممكن ان تخل توازنه
بحيث انه هنالك السائل الذي لا اعلم اسمه
طبيا في الاذنين اذا ما اختل بصير في دوار
يعني هذه ظاهره مرتبطه بالطب حقيقه لكن
ليس قبل فتره طويله ربما يكون يعني اذا
كان في هنالك اهتزازات اخلت بهذا التوازن
بدون احساس تدميري لدى الانسان قد يشعر
بشويه الدوار لكن لا يمكن تعميم ذلك يعني
قد يكون ايضا هنالك من يشعر بالدوار
لاسباب مختلفه تماما عن موضوع الزلزال في
هنالك نسبه يكون عندها يعني مشاكل بحيث
تؤدي الى هذا الدوار خارج اطار هذه
الاسباب طيب هناك شائعات بدات تنتشر بشكل
كبير على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لا نعلم
مصدرها بالطبع ولكنك تعلم دكتور ان وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي نشطه في هذا الامر بان
هناك
توقعات لانه قد تحدث فيض حوض البحر
المتوسط زلازل في بعض المناطق الاخرى
المجاوره لهذه المنطقه جغرافيا التي حدث
فيها الزلزال هل هناك اساس علمي يمكن
للاستناد اليه في توقع هذه الظواهر ام
انها فقط هي من باب الاشاعات
هي في الواقع من باب التكهنات التي انبهرت
قليلا تصبح اشاعات واذا تم العنايه بها من
الاجهزه معنيه يمكن ان يكون لها اهداف وفي
الواقع كله كله ممكن لكن ان يصبح هنالك في
البحر امور طبعا هذا قد يكون مرتبط مثلا
بهزر ارتداديه في البحر هذا نستطيع ان
نفهم ولكن ان يحصل هذا اوتوماتيكيا نتيجه
هذا الزلزال الذي يمكن ان نفكر بانه تكرر
يعني مئات الاف المرات خلال العصور
الجيولوجيه هذا مستبعد اعتقد منطقيا طيب
هل سمى الدراسات يمكن ان تتم الان للتربه
والارض التي وقع فيها محيط هذا
الزلزال يمكن ان تنبا بطبيعه القادم هل
يمكن ان تكون هناك هزات اخرى ارتداديه هل
يمكن ان يكون هناك زلزال اخر كما حدث
بالامس وازلزال ثاني وقع بدرجه ايضا 7.4
بالنسبه للهزاف الابتداديه ستكون يعني
حتما اسرع بكثير من نتائج خروج هكذا ابحاث
لانه هكذا قياسات وابحاث يعني تتطلب جهود
كبيره وامكانيات كبيره ووقت كبيره ايضا
على الحامي بهذا الشكل
استبعد ذلك يعني دراسه يمكن ان يستنتج
فيما بعد بعد التحليل لكل الابنيه التي
دمرت وما هي اساساتها وكذا يمكن ان يستفاد
هذا مستقبلا بحيث ان يزاد منسوب مقاومه
هذا النوع من التربه او وضع اساسات فيها
تقاوم الزلازل بشكل اكبر او انه ان يكون
بعض انواع المناطق اللي اساساتها رخوه
بهذا الشكل ان يكون استعمالات الاراضي لها
تستثني عمليه السكن فيها مثلا او بناء
ابراج او ما شابه ذلك يعني يستفيد الانسان
من كل نتائج هذه الكارثه اذا ما ذلك ووضع
الامكانيات اللازمه دكتور نجيب ابو كريكي
يا استاذ علم الزلازل في الجامعه الاردنيه
تحياتي لك دكتور
ونعرض على حضراتكم قائمه ببعض اشد الزلازل
فتكا على الصعيد العالميه في العقدين
المنصرمين بعدما ضرب زلزال بقوه 7.8 على
مقياس ريختر وسط تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا
اليوم وتسبب في مقتل الالف
ابرز الزلازل المميته حول العالم في
الرابع عشر من اغسطس عام 2021
درجه ومقتل ما يزيد عن 2200 شخص
في السادس عشر من ابريل عام 2016
الاكوادور زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه ومقتل 650
شخصا
في 25 من ابريل عام 2015
نيبال زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه وتسبب بمقتل
تسعه الاف شخص
الحادي عشر من مارس عام 2011 اليابان
زلزال مدمر بقوه تسع درجات خلف عشرين الفا
بين قتيل ومفقود السادس والعشرون من
ديسمبر عام 2003 ايران زلزال بقوه 6.6
درجه اسفر عن مقتل 31 الف شخص
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد يعد من اكبر
الكوارث الطبيعيه في التاريخ واكد ان
الدمار في المناطق المتضرره يتسبب في
اعاقه عمليات الانقاذ كما اعلن عن حاله
طوارئ في المناطق المتضرره تمتد لثلاثه
اشهر
هذا الزلزال يعد من اكبر الكوارث الطبيعيه
في التاريخ ومختلف القوى الامنيه
والعسكريه تشارك في عمليات الانقاذ لكن
الدمار في المناطق المتضرره يتسبب في
اعاقه هذه العمليات خصصنا اكثر من خمسه
مليارات دولار لعمليات الانقاذ وندعو كل
الدول لمساعدتنا بالمعدات اللازمه بغض
النظر عن الوضع السياسي وهناك 70 دوله
عرضت المساعده في البحث والانقاذ كذلك
هناك طائرات مسيره تشارك في عمليات
الانقاذ وتم انشاء 54 الف موقع للايواء في
مناطق الزلزال وهناك خطه لفتح فنادق
انطاليا امام المتضررين ونعلن حاله
الطوارئ في المناطق المتضرره التي ستستمر
لمده ثلاثه اشهر كما ان هناك عشر مدن
اعلنت كمناطق كوارث
الحلقه الاضعف عند وقوع اي كارثه انسانيه
والزلزال المدمر الذي هز تركيا وسوريا لم
يتركهم في حالهم بل عبثت هزاته بمصائر
الكثير منهما انهم اطفال تركيا وسوريا
الذين ذاقوا مراره الزلزال حالات انسانيه
مؤلمه واخرى تبعث الامل كان ابطالها اطفال
وجدوا انفسهم بين ليله وضحاها يعيشون وضعا
لا تتحمله براءتهما بلغه الارقام فان
حصيله الوفيات من الاطفال تبدو مرتفعه
فنقلا عن صندوق الامم المتحده للطفوله
يونيسيف فان حصيله الوفيات من الاطفال
تبدو مرتفعه ويصعب تحديدها بدقه لحد الان
مقاس الاطفال في هذا الزلزال تلخصها صور
كثيره من هنا وهناك صور تتحدث عن نفسها
وتعكس هول الكارثه التي المت بالكثير منهم
واوجعت ذويهم
الطفله السوريه رغد كتب لها عمر جديد
ستعيشه يتيمه بعدما فقدت معظمه افراد
عائلتها بسبب الزلزال
حال هذا الرضيع السوري لا يختلف عن حال
رغد فقد ولد وسط ركام متحديا هذه الكارثه
التي سرقت منه والدته اما هؤلاء الاطفال
فقد نفذوا بجلدهم من الموت بفضل هذا الثقب
الصغير الذي كان بالنسبه لهم بمثابه نافذه
حياه جديده وهذه الطفله بريئه ربما لم
تستوعب جيدا هول ما حدث واكتفت بالصمت
تعبيرا عن الصدمه
اما البعض فلم تسعه الدنيا من الفرحه
بعدما منحته فرصه ثانيه لمعانقه ابنه او
ابنته عكس اخرين الذين لم يجدوا سوى
الدموع لتوضيع اطفالهم الذين رحلوا تحت
الانقاضى الذهبي العربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العديد من الصور والقصص المؤلمه ستبقى
حاضره بالطبع قالت المتحدثه باسم الامم
المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه ان تدفق مساعدات
المنظمه المهمه من تركيا الى شمال غرب
سوريا توقفت مؤقتا بسبب الاضرار التي لحقت
بالطرق الى جانب مشكله اللوجيسيه اخرى
مرتبطه بتداعيات الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب
البلدين واكدت المتحدثه ان بعض الطرق
معطله والبعض الاخر لا يمكن الوصول اليه
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه يا عمو
[موسيقى]
شوي شوي على الحديد
تمام تمام الله يجزيك الخير يا رب بسم
الله
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
الينا عهد الصليبي الصحفي في شبكه نهر
ميديا مرحبا بك عهد بالتاكيد الوضع صعب
للغايه من الناحيه المتعلقه بكيفيه وصول
المساعده المشكله ليست في رز المساعدات
الان ولكن في كيفيه الوصول هل يمكن بالفعل
ان تتم اتصالات ما بين جناحي السلطه في
سوريا المعارضه والنظام لتنسيق هذا الامر
مساء الخير لك والاستاذ المشاهدين انا لا
اعتقد ان النظام السوري سيعمل على هذا
القرار اساسا وبالتالي ستكون المعادله
كلها غير موجوده
بشكل مطلق النظام السوري كذلك الامر هو
الان يعمل على حشد ان كل هذه الماساه التي
حصلت في سوريا تخضع او حدثت في مناطق هو
يسيطر عليها قمنا نحن في على الطرف الاخر
في المعارضه السوريه بالحديث عن ان
الماساه الكبرى هي في مناطق الشمال السوري
المحرر الذي هو خارج سيطره القوات
الحكوميه هذه المساله يعمل عليها النظام
منذ وقت طويل بان يغلق جميع معابر
المنافذ الحدوديه للمساعدات
هذا منفذ مهم يمكن الاعتماد عليه في توصيل
المساعدات الى المحتاجين
تم تجديد العقد سته اشهر قبل نحو شهر ونصف
بشكل دوري هو يجدد العقد كل سته اشهر
المره الماضيه كانت هي المره السادسه في
تجديد هذا العقد لادخال المساعدات نحو
مناطق المعارضه السوريه في شمال غربيه
سوريا كان يعمل هذا المعبر بشكل روتيني
وطبيعي عبر الحدود من الاراضي التركيه لكن
بعدما التي حدثت كان مركزها جنوب التركي
الماسات التركيه ربما يعني حدت اوقفت
المساعدات باتجاه الشمال السوري الذي ايضا
هو تضرر بشكل كبير والذي ليس له سوى هذا
المنفذ الوحيد باتجاه الاراضي هل هو الان
مفتوح الجهود تتم لاعاده فتح ماذا عن وضع
تحديدا
باب الهواء
واقعيا هو غير مفتوح يعني اتجاه المساء
التي حصلت هناك بعض الحالات النادره تدخل
وتخرج من والى سوريا عبر هذا المنفذ وكذلك
الامر المنافذ الاخرى تتحدثن عن المنافذ
غير الرسميه والمنافذ العسكريه كمنفذ
الحمام في ريف عفرين والمنافذ الاخرى في
الشيخ حديد والمنافذ الاخرى في ريف عزاز
ومعبر باب السلامه الشرعي كلها تعمل لكن
بشكل يعتبر قليل او اقل حتى من قبل حدوث
هذا الزلزال اذا هي مقارنه بالحجم الماساه
هي لا تعمل واقعيا هنا طيب الجهود التي
تتم لاغاثه العالقين وجهود الانقاذ في هذه
المناطق على ماذا تعتمد
يعني هناك الاعتماد بالدرجه الاولى على
المنظمات التي كانت تخزن شيء قليل من مما
يردها في خلال السنوات الماضيه تم
استهلاكه بشكل شبه تام في هذه الماساه اذا
تحدثنا عن منظمه الدفاع المدني السوري
التي حقيقه هذه المنظمه التي قدمت شيء
يعني يحتذى به ويعني يدعو للفقر لدى لكل
السوريين الان المنظمه تعمل ليلا نهارا
على انتشال الجرحى والعالقين تحت الانقاض
حتى هذه اللحظه قبل قليل وردتني بعض الصور
من مدينه سلقين بعد انتشار الاخبار عن
وفاه كل ما كل من هم بداخل هذه البنايه
اخرجوا طفلتين على قيد الحياه بعد مرور
نحو 48 ساعه من حدوث الزلزال او اقل من
ذلك بكثير اذا منظمه الدفاع المدني عليها
الاعتماد بشكل شبه كامل وهناك بعض
المنظمات الاخرى التي هي مخصصه في الاغاثه
لكنها اضطرت للعمل في العمل في انتشار
القتلى من تحت الانقاظ فقط هذه هي الجهود
التي تعمل في الشمال الغربي من سوريا
المعابر الان تحاول بعض يعني القوى
المعارضه لنظام السوري بان تفتح الممر من
اوروبا الى تركيا مرورا عبر
اوروبا عبر سوريا مرورا
الصوت يتقطع ولكنك كنت تتحدث عن محاوله
عبور المساعدات من اوروبا الى الشمال
السوري عهد صليبه الصحفي في شبكه نهر
ميديا شكرا لك على هذه المعلومات
ومن عمان تنضموا الينا رولا الامينه
المتحدثه باسم مفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا مرحبا بك يا رولا هناك
اسئله كثيره تتعلق بكم من مساعدات التي تم
رصدها ولكن بدايه هناك تساؤلات تتعلق
بكيفيه وصول هذه المساعدات بالفعل المشكله
الان التي يفكر فيها الكثيرون ليست في رز
مساعدات بكم كبير ولكن النجاح في وصول هذه
المساعدات للمتضررين
يعني لنكن واقعيين هناك اليات لايصال
المساعدات طبعا هناك تحديات كبيره بسبب
الطقس وبسبب الزلزال وبسبب السياسه ولكن
هناك اليات موجوده وتعتمدها المفوضيه
والوكالات الاغاثه الاخرى منذ سنوات
لايصال المساعدات سواء داخل سوريا في
المناطق التي تحت سلطه الحكومه او في
مناطق التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه نحن
موجودون على الارض في داخل سوريا وقد
تمكنا من ارسال مساعدات طارئه من خيام من
بلاستيكيه بطانيات فرشات الى الاماكن
المتضرره مثل حماه وغيرها وبدانا بالتوزيع
منذ ليله امس في الشمال السوري لدينا
مخزون ولدينا شركاء على المخزون موجود في
الشمال السوري
بمواد اغاثيه مشابهه ولدينا شركاء على
الارض يحاولون الوصول الى معظم المناطق
المتضرره ولكن هناك تحديات طيب رولا يقال
ان الطرق تعوق مساله وصول هذه المساعدات
التقارير اللوجستيه من على الارض كيف تقيم
لك الوضع صحيح وهذا ما كنت اود ان اقوله
هناك تحديات لان الطرق على سبيل المثال
التي تسلكها الشاحنات والسيارات الكبيره
لايصال المساعدات من تركيا الى الشمال
السوري هذه الطرق قد تاثرت بالزلزال خاصه
في الجانب التركي وقد تصدعت فهناك اعتاقات
ويتم العمل عليها في داخل الشمال الغرب
سوريا هناك ايضا اعاقات في الطرق هناك
العاصفه الثلجيه البارده جدا والقويه جدا
والتي ادت ايضا الى اغلاق بعض الطرق
الكهرباء قد انطقم انقطعت وكذلك الانترنت
في معظم الاماكن لذلك لا يوجد لدينا حتى
الان صوره شامله عن مدى الخسائر
الاحتياجات ولكن لدينا شركاء على الارض
موجودون وهم وهذا هو الوضع عاده موجودون
على الارض ويحاولون الوصول الى الجميع
ولكن الموضوع ياخذ وقتا اكثر مما
مفرود ولكن هناك جهود جباره للوصول الى
جميع المنكوبين والاماكن المتضرره طيب
هناك سؤال ربما يدور الان في الاذان رولا
هل تمت اتصالات سياسيه ترعاها الامم
المتحده لتمكين فرق الانقاذ والمفوضيه
الخاصه بالامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
والمساعدات الانسانيه ليفتح لكم الطريق من
الناحيه التواصلات السياسيه هكذا اقصد
نعم الامم المتحده طبعا انت تعرفين هناك
جهات مختلفه كل يعني بشان معين صحيح
بالنسبه
لفتح معابر اخرى غير باب الهوى وغير التي
تستعمل والتي كانت تستعمل خلال السنوات
القادمه هذا
امر مهم ويجب ان تتضافر الجهود ويجب ان
يتعاون الجميع على توفير كافه السبل
لتامين الاغاثه للذين يحتاجون ساسالك عن
هذه التفاصيل ولكن قولي لي وفقا للتقارير
التي تصل اليك باب الهوى مفتوح ام مغلق
معبر باب الهوى يعني لا اريد ان اقول مغلق
بالكامل لانه هو التباب هو مفتوح ولكن
الطرقات قد تصدعت من جراء الزلزال وهذا
يعني ان الشاحنات الكبيره
والتي كانت تنقل الغذاء لديها صعوبه في
اخذ هذا الطريق خاصه على جانب التركي
المساعدات تصل الى الشمال السوري عبر
تركيا
بقرار من مجلس الامن
باتفاق بين الدول الخمس الموجوده على
المجلس الامن وخاصه الولايات المتحده
وروسيا وهل يلتزم النظام السوري بهذه
القرارات هل يتعاون في هذا الشان يعني هو
النظام السوري مش موجود على هذه الحدود
ولكن الامم المتحده القرار هو حتى يتيح
للامم المتحده نقل المساعدات عبر الحدود
بدون موافقه الحكومه السوريه هذا هو
القرار اقول
ولكن المعارضه تقول انه من الصعب وصول
المساعدات اذا لم تسمح حكومه بشار الاسد
بدخول هذه المساعدات الى شمال السوري
هناك اليات متعدده نحن كما ايضا نحاول
هناك بعض المساعدات التي تصل من المناطق
التي يسيطر عليها الحكومه السوريه ونسميها
كروس اي هي يعني نعبر خطوط التماس بين
مناطق الحكومه ومناطق المعارضه هذه ايضا
نحن نبحث مع الحكومه وكل الجهات المختصه
لامكانيه زياده دخول المساعدات عن هذا
الطريق لتامين اكبر قدر من المواد
الاغاثيه الى داخل والى شمال غرب سوريا
حيث الحاجه كبيره جدا الحاجه طبعا كبيره
في كل الاماكن التي وصل اليها الزلزال
ونحن ندعو الجميع الى وضع السياسه جانبا
والتركيز على الاحتياجات في الانسانيه
وعدم تسييس المساعدات الانسانيه لان فعلا
كيف تقيمين مستوى الاغاثه وجود الانقاذ
المقدمه الان الى الشمال السوري هل مساومه
منخفض متوسط مطمئن متص
يعني الزلزال حدث يا ليله امس او خلينا
لنقل فجر وهذا يعني ان الوقت يعني ما زال
غير كاتبه نحكم الجميع يحاول جاهدا ان تصل
المساعدات باسرع وقت ممكن ولكن كما قلت
اثار الزلزال والعاصفه طبعا تضامع معوقات
وعوائق جديه امام ادخال المزيد من
المساعدات هناك مساعدات موجوده داخل
الشمال السوري في المخازن وهناك شركاء
الارض يستعملونها لاصالها الى المتضررين
ولكن الاحتياجات كبيره لذلك نقول ان تاتي
مساعدات اخرى والمزيد منها ونحن يعني
نطالب الجميع والمجتمع الدولي والافراد
وشركات الخاصه بالتعاون لارسال المزيد من
المساعده حتى نتمكن من الوصول الى ساسالك
على ما فهمته من ان الاعتماد في جهود
الانقاذ الان يتم على المخزون المتوفر لدى
شركاء في هذه المنظمات على الارض ولكن
اسمحي لنا هناك عرض لبعض التقارير
الانسانيه نجح رجال الخوذه البيضاء في
سوريا بانقاذ طفل علقه تحت ركام المنزل
الذي كان يسكن به وعلى الرغم من اصابته
وبقائه تحت الانقاض لساعات طويله الا ان
فرق الانقاذ اكدت ان الطفل تم اخراجه وهو
بصحه جيده
يعمل
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
روح روح روح
[موسيقى]
يا رب
وهذه هي طبيعه الكوارث الانسانيه اختلاط
ما بين الموت والنجاه ما بين الموت
والحياه اعود مره اخرى الى عمان الى
الاستاذه رولا الامينه المتحدثه باسم
مفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
رولا من المبكر الحديث عن احصائيات تتعلق
بالناجين او المتضررين ولكن هناك تساؤلات
تتعلق بالارقام المتوقعه بشان الاطفال لان
هناك عدد كبير من الصور والفيديوهات تتعلق
بالاطفال
لا استطيع ان اتنبا برقم الان ولكن لاننا
لا نستطيع ليس فقط المفوضيه بالجميع
وكالات الاغاثه من الوصول الى جميع
المناطق المنكوبه يصعب تحديد رقم ولكن
نتوقع ان الارقام عن الخسائر البشريه
والدمار ستزداد وهذا للاسف طبعا يعني
الوضع المحسن وكارثي جدا جدا جدا ولهذا
نناشد الجميع في عدم تاحه المجال للسياسه
للوقوف امام الاغاثه الانساني يجب ان
نتذكر ان الشعب السوري المدنيين يدفعون
الثمن الاكبر منذ 12 سنه في هذه والان هم
يدفعون هذا التمن مضاعفه لذلك يجب ان نكون
هناك التزام بمساعدتهم بغض النظر اين هم
والى من ينتمون ومن
يسيطرات لمجلس الامن تلزم الجميع بضروره
تامين وصول المساعدات الى المتضررين بغض
النظر عن اي حدود او اتفاقيات سياسيه اخرى
يعني هناك قرار منذ عام
2014 هناك قرار من مجلس الامن بتمكين
الامم المتحده من ادخال المساعدات عبر
التركيه الى الشمال غرب سوريا ولكن افراد
الامم المتحده غير مخولين بالدخول يعني
نحن نرسل الشاحنات ونرسل المواد الاغاثه
والقيام والبطانيات والغذاء كله عبر تركيا
ولكن لدينا شركاء على الارض سوريون
ومنظمات اغاثه دوليه غير متابعه للامم
المتحده هي من يقوم بالتوزيع هذه الاليه
اوسخ سمح فيها مجلس الامن وعلى اساسها يتم
ادخالها هذه المساعده
تتم حسب السياسه
يعني اتفاق الدول الكبرى على هذا القرار
والذي
اتخذ بعض المفاوضات
التركيه قال اليوم في تصريحاته انه سيقوم
بتقديم المساعدات بغض النظر عن اي خلافات
سياسيه ولكن قبل التقرير كنت اسالك رولا
عن
المساعدات هل نجحت مساعدات جديده في
الدخول بالفعل الى الشمال السوري ام انكم
تعتمدون على مخزون المساعدات المتوافر لدى
الشركاء على الارض وهو مخزون سابق وليس
لاحق لهذه الكارثه
صحيح حتى الان وحسب ما اعرف
الاعتماد الان على المخزون الموجود نحن
نعمل على ادخال المزيد ولكن يجب ان نتذكر
ان الارضيه هذا الزلزال حدث وكان نقطه
الوسط فيه هي مدينه غازي منطقه غازي عنتاب
وهذه المنطقه التي يتخذها جميع الوكالات
الاغاثه ووكالات الامم المتحده
كموقع قيادي
يعني كبيت لهم حتى يتمكنوا من تنسيق
المساعدات وادخالها الى الشمال السوري
فحتى زملائنا قد تهدمت بيوتهم ومكاتبهم
وهم يعملون من خلال سياراتهم او في الوقت
في يعني في العرب لانهم لا يستطيعون ان
يذهبوا الى مكاتبهم فاليه اتقال المساعدات
الى الشمال الغربي من سوريا كلها قد تاثرت
بهذا
يعني هناك محاولات كما قلت لك مثلا الطريق
الذي تاثر على الجانب التركي هناك يعني
محاولات حديثه لاصلاحه باسرع وقت ممكن حتى
تتمكن الشاحنات من استعماله والدخول لذلك
كان يقال يوسف الطرق دائما بانها شريان
الحياه لان من خلال هذه الطرق يتم توصيل
المساعدات اسمحي لنا ان نشير الى هذا
العاجل المركز السوري يقول ان عدد ضحايا
الزلزال في سوريا تجاوز الالفي قتيل هذا
هو الرقم الاخير ايضا هناك ارقام تتعلق
بارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال ايضا في عموم
سوريا الى هذا الرقم وفقا للمرصد السوري
الفي قتيل
رولا بخبرتك الدوليه في هذا المجال
بالتاكيد زلزال من هذا النوع وسط ظروف
متغيره للغايه مزيد من الارتدادات الارضيه
مستمره او الهزات الارتداديه الطقس السيء
للغايه تقطع الطرق جهود الاغاثه يمكن ان
تاخذ شهور
لا يجب ان لا تاخذ شهور ولا اسابيع الوضع
لا يحتمل ان تاخذ اسابيع ولا ايام يعني
نحن هناك شركاء لنا ووكلات الامم المتحده
الاخرى الكل يعمل جاهدا ربما يستطيعون
ارسال بعض المساعدات غدا صباحا لذلك لا
نريد التحويل بان الانسان هذه اخبار جيده
للغايه انتم تحاولون انا عم بقول انا مش
عم بقول راح يصير بكره الصبح انا بقول ما
عندي وقت بقدر اقول فيه ولكن بالتاكيد
ليست المساله مساله شهور وبالتاكيد ليست
مساله اسابيع وربما غدا ربما بعد غد لا
اعتقد ان الامر يحتمل اكثر من ذلك طيب هل
لديكم اتصالات بالمكتب السياسيه
للامم المتحده تحوطونه علما بتطورات بان
هناك صعوبات تواجهكم في جهود الانقاذ حتى
يتم اتصال سياسي او تنسيق ما او عقد جلسه
لمجلس الامن لاتخاذ قرارات بهذا الامر
لابد ان تتحرك السياسه ايضا على الجانب
الاخر عبر تقارير تصدر منكم هكذا يتوقع
البعض
يعني الامين العام قد تحدث في الموضوع منذ
اول يوم
وهو على ايصال المساعدات وعلى تامين
المساعدات وتامين التمويل لارسال
المساعدات وانا متاكده انهم يبحثون مع
جميع الاطراف كيفيه حل كل وتجاوز كل هذه
العقبات لا اتحدث انا مع الامين العام
ولكن جميع وكالات الامم المتحده تنصر
وهناك مكتب تنسيق الاغاثه مكتب مخصص
لتنسيق جميع الجهود الاغاثه للدخل السوري
وفي اي مكان في العالم وهم جميعا بتعاون
وسيق ومعرفه وثيقه مع مكتب الامين العام
وجميع المسؤولين عن الوضع هل تواجهون
صعوبات هل تتمكنوا هل هناك عوائق انت
تعلمين اكثر مني طبعا هناك تنسيق تامهم
يعلمون ويعملون على تجاوز هذه العقبات
يعني لا نريد ان نهول ايضا من
يعني لا نريد ان نعطي صوره وكانه لا يوجد
اغاثه لان الزملائي موجودون على الارض
موجودون على الارض في داخل سوريا وموجودين
في غازي عنتاب يجب ان نتذكر كذلك انه حتى
في تركيا في المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
هناك الاف وعشرات الانوثه من اللاجئين
السوريين وهم ايضا تاثروا وهم ايضا خسروا
عائلاتهم وهم ايضا
فالغاء تتصل الى كل من نستطيع الوصول اليه
ولكن حينما يكون هناك
كارثه كان زلزال حتى جهود الاغاثه تتاثر
وهذا يحدث في اي مكان في العالم وليس فقط
اشكرك رولا الامين المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا تحياتي
ستون ثانيه ليس اكثر وقعها مدمر
وارتداداتها اكثر تدميرا ولا تزال متواصله
تلك هي مده زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وغير حياه اكثر من 23 مليون شخص
زلزال بقوه 7.9 درجه ضرب في السادس من
فبراير على عمق نحو 17 كيلومترا
والان ننتقل الى مؤتمر صحفي لهيئه الكوارث
التركيه
[موسيقى]
السيد نائب رئيس الجمهوريه بعد الاجتماع
التنسيقي السيد فؤاد اقطينه رئيس
الجمهوريه يفيد بتصريحاته
حتى ذلك اشكركم وارجو السلامه للمواطنين
طاب مسائكم
اذا
كانت هذه افاده سريعه لرئيس اداره الكوارث
التركيه والتي اشار فيها الى ارتفاع عدد
القتلى الى 4000 الى
4544 والجرحى الى 26
و725 حتى اللحظه وان هناك سيكون هناك
مؤتمر صحفي بعد قليل نائب رئيس
النائب الرئيس التركي اردوغان سيتم فيه
عرض اخر النتائج وجهود الانقاذ التغطيه
مستمره مع حضراتكم وننتقل الان الى
الزميله ريم ابو جمره وساعه جديده من هذه
التغطيه